[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is Alex mullering and tonight I
am revisiting a topic so I don't know
exactly how long ago but a little while
a few months uh maybe ago we did a video
on this channel I did on forcing moves I
believe it's called forcing their hand
feel free to look it up it is not
required viewing before you see this one
but I'm actually revisiting the topic
for three reasons first one it's just
that important a topic forcing moves I
think is one of the most critical things
you can learn that will bring your game
from a beginner level into a more
intermediate stage our second reason is
in the last lecture
um I gave kind of a basic definition of
forcing moves that lacks some nuance and
I'm afraid it might mislead people
uh kind of the third reason ties into
that is I didn't really articulate my
process for how to apply forcing moves
in your games I just kind of showed some
examples and I think they were good
examples they're still relevant but I
want to work more on how to apply
forcing moves and really understanding
it in depth so without further Ado let's
jump into it
uh to kind of help us redefine and just
restate what's going on here I want to
start with looking at morphe's Opera
House game we're not going to go all the
way through it but it's a really famous
game and it's really helpful for a lot
of different reasons but let's just take
a quick look at what happens so morphe
begins with E4 his opponents play E5 we
have Knight to F3 attacking the pawn on
e4 D6 defending this is the Philadelphia
defense that's not very relevant for
this video but it's what that move is
called defending the pawn on E5
D4 attacking the pawn and uh already
there's sort of a forcing move going on
um this is kind of a threat right and
this will make more sense when we
understand our definition of a forcing
move
a forcing move the way I would like to
redefine it
is a move that forces the other player
to immediately respond or suffer a
serious disadvantage so it's again it's
a move that forces the opponent to
respond or suffer a disadvantage the
other kind of piece of forcing moves is
they really limit the amount of moves an
opponent can play in response so let's
consider what's going on here with the
move d4 morphe is attacking the center
but he's also very simply making an
attack on this Pawn in the same way that
Knight to F3 attacks the pawn on E5 this
is a forcing move black has to do
something but it's not the reason I
wouldn't think of it as much of a
forcing move is because black has so
many ways to respond you can respond by
defending the pawn with this Pawn as
happened in the game or with this Knight
you could play some maybe dubious moves
like defending it with the bishop or the
queen
you could not defend it at all and
counter-attack our Pawn there's just a
lot of options so I don't think it's as
useful in when thinking about forcing
moves if there's just a ton of options
you really want your opponent to be
limited in how they can respond
so let's continue D4 the threat is we're
going to take this Pawn on E5 and we're
going to take twice we have two
attackers black only has one Defender so
they need to do something and in the
game Bishop to G4 was chosen again maybe
not the most critical example of forcing
move because there are a lot of options
right you can add more Defenders to this
Pawn
even if it's not a good move you can do
it you can still counter-attack this
weak E4 Pawn with something like that F6
there's just a lot of potential options
here you could play Knight C6
so Bishop G4 was the option actually
chosen in the game which is removing
this as an attacker of the pawn because
now the Knight is pinned if the Knight
moves then the queen will be taken so
you don't want to do that
in the game morphe plays D take C5
taking the pawn and we reach kind of a
critical moment if you haven't analyzed
this game
um there's some other videos there's a
lot of videos on the Opera House game
it's one of the most famous ones in
chess history but the idea here is
actually a little more complicated black
would like to just retake the pawn but
the problem is if they retake then we
can force a trade of Queens
and then notice how our Queen is no
longer on D1 meaning this Knight is not
pinned and we could eat this extra Pawn
so in the game that's not what happened
um we've played a forcing move right we
captured a piece if black doesn't do
something about that then we're just
going to be up a pawn
and that would already be a significant
disadvantage just being down even a pawn
can mean a lot if you're going to give
it away for free so black has to do
something to try and maintain the
material or gain some positional Edge
that compensates and in this case they
play the right move because taking here
is not so good they play Bishop takes F3
and now we're going to start to see
another level here right so a capture is
a forcing move this is maybe a higher
order forcing move or a higher tier than
the previous one this takes upon this
takes a knight so already the piece is
higher value and it also attacks the
queen
so
um
you want to be careful with your forcing
moves we'll talk about this more later
on in the lecture but you want to make
sure it's actually really forcing your
opponent into doing something that's
beneficial
okay for our purposes here white plays
Queen takes F3
black retakes the pawn and the material
has equalized but White's going to go on
to play a few more moves white plays on
another very forcing move here Bishop to
C4 developing a piece and opening up
space to Castle yes so following good
opening principles but also making a
threat against this really vulnerable F7
Pawn it's only defended by the king and
so now if black doesn't do something
about this threat we are going to on our
next move play Queen takes F7 and call
Checkmate so black really needs to do
something here
um what they do in the game is Knight to
F6 which is okay but morphe still has a
really nice response Queen to B3 lining
up the queen and Bishop again so
renewing the threat again our threat is
not Checkmate this time but it is to
take this Pawn Force the king to move
not be able to Castle
but also we're threatening on B7 here so
this is a fork morphe is a master of
efficiency he's doing a lot of making
moves that have multiple purposes but
what I want you to focus on here is just
the forcing nature right black needs to
do something in this case they evaluate
the the threat to this Pawn is not as
serious as the one here because this one
accesses The Rook but this one accesses
the king and the king is the most
important piece
so black plays Queen to E7 and we're
just going to look at like two more
moves
this actually lays a bit of a trap and
we can see it if again we think about
forcing moves the move morphe plays in
the game is very good he plays Knight C3
just being very solid and safe
developing a piece and preparing to
continue his attack in the center
could he been a little more greedy and
played Queen takes Pawn on B7 then even
though he's going to win this Pawn black
now can use forcing moves to try and uh
make it as close as possible they have
to do something about this Rook they
don't want to just give it up but this
move Queen E7 actually laid a little bit
of a trap because now after Queen to B4
check we have a very common example of a
forcing move right check is probably the
the the poster child for forcing moves
because you have to by the rules of the
game keep your king safe
um in this case it forces a queen trade
which makes the queen not able to attack
this Rook
and Bishop takes and black is down upon
but doing okay with their pieces being
active they have a little bit of
initiative we're not here to analyze
this game in really deep detail but it I
do think it illustrates kind of our
forcing moves so again to repeat the
definition that I'm using for a forcing
move here a forcing move is a move that
forces your opponent or if your
opponent's doing it to you it forces you
but it forces the other player to
immediately respond to that move
directly or suffer some serious
disadvantage forcing Loops also tend to
limit the number of possible responses
okay
so now I want to kind of contrast this
with a very common definition and one
that I sort of used in the last video on
forcing moves that we did on this
channel the kind of common definition of
a forcing move that many people just
default to is that forcing moves are
checks captures and threats
and while this is a true definition I do
think it can be a little misleading so I
want to explain
um
think about the relationship between
rectangles and squares in this case you
can see I've kind of made this this is
the box for those who are familiar with
kind of Pawn promotion and how to catch
upon but that's beyond the topic but the
box here we have a square right it's the
same amount of
I guess square of squares in this case
of units uh long as it is tall a
rectangle could be a little farther it
could be a little shorter
but the difference between these two is
that even though both are four-sided
four-sided shapes with four right angles
each side of a square has to be the same
length while rectangles can have uneven
lengths what this means is that all
squares are rectangles but not all
rectangles are squares okay this is not
a math list and this is a chest lesson
so how is this relevant
well I think the common definition of
forcing moves operates in a very similar
way all checks captures and threats are
forcing moves yes but not all forcing
moves must be checks captures and
threats at least obvious ones
and let's consider a few examples to
kind of illustrate this point
this is a very unusual end game we have
dead even material I guess it's a bishop
pair versus a knight and a bishop so
slight imbalance but basically material
is totally equal it's just one side has
a bishop for a night
however Black's pieces are very poorly
placed here
um this bishop is on the back rank
defending the Knight the king is kind of
trapped on the edge of the board by
arcing and this Knight is pinned to the
king
in almost any other circumstance this
end game would be a draw but because
Black's pieces are so cramped white
actually has a way to win and so I want
to kind of Walk Through This by looking
at forcing moves
most people would say okay what's the
name of the obvious forcing move here it
would be a capture and a check Bishop
takes on C7
but there's a problem with this move
Bishop takes C7 just invites black to
recapture Bishop takes I mean if they
move to the corner it's Checkmate so
they don't want to do that but Bishop
takes kind of the obvious move and now
we can't recapture their Bishop is
defended by their King we have to move
our King and we have opposite colored
Bishops there's nothing else on the
board this is a very very easy draw
there's actually even if one side
blunders one of their Bishops there's
still no way to force a win with just a
king and a bishop against a king so this
would be a draw
so our most forcing move uh is not
really effective here but if we expand
our definition to what we said before we
want to play a move that forces our
opponent to respond in a very specific
way or suffer consequences
and we want to really limit the moves
our opponent can play
we actually have some options here and
someone in the chat uh subash Chandra
Bose I believe uh says we need to play a
waiting move with our Bishop so we just
need to delay there's actually a very
important reason for this so let's just
pick an idea here let's play Bishop to
D6 and just say we're just going to wait
we're going to do the same thing as
before
this doesn't really seem like a forcing
move but I actually want you to think
about this particular position
black cannot move their Knight they have
no moves with it
um if they move their Bishop anywhere
right it has to be on one of these
squares I mean if they move it here I
guess we can just take it but if they
move it to any of these spaces then
they're not defending their Knight
anymore
any move the bishop takes and it moves
I'm sorry we take the Knight and it's
not defended anymore
the King has one legal move and
checkmate
so two of Black's pieces can't move
and black actually only has one move
they can only move their King to A8 if
they don't want to do one of these two
pieces so we have completely limited
what they can do
from here we can kind of reconsider our
forcing moves and it's kind of the nice
obvious idea would be to call check
Bishop to F3
um if the King goes back this is a
little more high level than this class
might be ready for so that's okay we're
actually going to invoke a concept
called zuk Swang and force our opponent
to have to play a move they don't want
to play in this case the move is Bishop
to B7
because now this King can't move to
either of these squares we've taken
control from both of them away the
knights still can't move because it's
pinned which means everything we said
before about this bishop moving now has
to happen it has to move somewhere and
wherever it moves we take the Knight and
it's checkmate
there is a slight problem with this
though
after Bishop F3 black does not have to
play King back they can actually play
the really smart move Knight to D5
check
double check
we can't take the Knight because then
our King gets taken by the bishop so we
have to move our King out of the way and
really wherever we move it
um black will have just enough time to
survive it's actually not easy to do but
if they play something like Bishop C7
and force a trait of one of one set of
these pieces then they will be okay
even again even if we win one of these
two it's not going to be enough to force
a win of the whole game
but we can learn from this and say okay
we need to do this idea but our waiting
move can't allow this Knight to
eventually come to D5 so we want to play
a bishop move that doesn't let this get
blockaded
and the actual solution here is to play
Bishop to D7
it's again a weird way to think about
forcing moves but we are significantly
limiting how our opponent can respond if
they move the bishop anywhere we take
the Knight and win
so they have to move their King and we
can repeat what we saw before check this
time they can't block with the Knight
they only can go here and we repeat what
just happened before the bishop will
have to move and we get a Checkmate this
is a complex example I would not expect
you if you're coming to this being in
our breakdown class to maybe find this
in your game but I do think it's helpful
to think to broaden our understanding of
forcing those Beyond just simple checks
and captures right it can mean more than
that and here let's give a little more
example an illustration to help show
what I mean further
another reason I like the definition of
forcing move I'm presenting here more
than the just kind of common checks
captures threats is because sometimes
checks captures and threats aren't that
forcing and sometimes they just aren't
even good moves
um so here's an example uh in this game
let's just play some very simple moves
E4 E6 D4 D5 we have a French defense
Knight to D2 defending our Pawn
let's say black takes and we take back
and in this position black has an option
they can play the forcing move Bishop to
B4
but let me ask the kind of audience here
do we think Bishop to B4 check would be
a good move yes or no
one or two things
and even though one of your straight out
useless Knight back to D2 is a waste of
a move
not the most forcing move but a forcing
move
because you are attacking the Bishops
and you are developing a piece
yeah so we could play Bishop D2 and
develop I think that would be good I
think probably even better we like you
said we have a lot of options we can
block with a knight we could even block
with a knight on Seether if we really
wanted
um I think the best move here is just
Pawn to C3
ways yeah we're gonna we're gonna
solidify our Center we're attacking the
bishop which means they have to spend an
extra move just moving away
um so they're wasting time moving this
bishop a lot while they're just helping
us do what we want we want to solidify
the center the only reason we might not
want to play C3 is because it's a good
Square for the night but our Knight's
already in the middle so that doesn't
really matter anymore
um so yeah this is not a great check
let me show you a worse one
let's look at this game D4 Knight F6 F3
I know unusual generally I wouldn't
recommend playing this move at the
beginner level but there's some ideas to
it E6 E4 B6 bit of unusual Pawn play
from both sides
E5 in this case Bishop to B4 the same
idea is actually way worse because now
when we play C3 we could also block with
other pieces but C3 is the best move
because we've created two threats
right so just because you can play a
check or a capture and force something
to happen does not necessarily mean that
it's going to be in your favor in this
case black solved the problem of their
Knight being attacked by attacking our
King
but then we solved that problem by
attacking their bishop and they can't
save both pieces
so those are some cases where checks
even though they're forcing aren't super
useful here's a case where a capture
isn't that useful
so take a look and I want to ask you in
this position it's Black's turn to move
and let's say you're considering the
move Knight takes E4 just trading the
knights
what might lead you towards or away from
that decision
say more
oh you said say more yeah yeah so say
more about that
yeah so it's defended it would just be a
trade yeah but there's a more concrete
reason why this is a problem
because sometimes you're okay with
trades in this case there's a lot of
material in the center maybe we would
want to spend some time and just get rid
of some of it so there could be
Arguments for it but there's actually a
very specific reason we don't want to do
that in this example
there's a big problem with Knight takes
E4
yeah
I believe it's you have to
you allowed
once again in Temple because
your Bishop is hit
so it's you're you're right it's
actually worse than that
if Knight takes C4 and a lot of people
in chat have found the right answer and
suggested thank you for commenting
um the problem is very simple
if we take on e4 we are significantly
improving light's pieces because not
Bishop takes Bishop takes is kind of
equal if Queen takes we now have two
threats
light is threatening to take our Bishop
white is also batteried up with their
Bishop threatening checkmate
we cannot stop both we are either losing
our king or our Bishop and so you have
to do something about the threat
white wins a piece
so here's a kind of a classic example of
where a capture is not even though it's
a forcing move it's not good now does
that mean forcing moves are not useful
or not valuable Quite Contrary but we'll
get to that in a second the basic idea
is
even though this is not a good move we
can still use the idea of forcing moves
to quickly rule it out we can say okay
we're going to capture whites Limited in
their responses they either have to take
back with one of these pieces it's the
only way they can try and stay in the
game
um
and we can quickly see okay wait a
minute if they take with the if they
take here with the queen then we are in
serious trouble
um probably so some people are
suggesting better moves in the position
here probably Knight takes D5 is very
good Bishop to F5 might be okay but
again you want to look out for forcing
moves so want to be a little nervous of
this discovered check Knight takes F6
and then maybe they take our Bishop it's
a little complicated but maybe there's
some ideas to it okay but let's move
right along to our next idea here
so okay so why do we emphasize forcing
moves especially me like I'm telling you
these are really important but I've
given you so many reasons why you
shouldn't trust them let's actually
explore why are these so important and
how can they elevate your chess game
I've got three reasons there's probably
more but I've boiled it down to three
first one the main reason they maximize
efficiency in our calculations
second reason they induce creativity and
help us look beyond the natural
intuitive moves and three they can
actually reveal things about the
position to us that we wouldn't have
seen if we didn't look at them we're
going to break those down one at a time
so if efficiency creativity and kind of
revealing truths about the position
let's look at that first idea
the main reason forcing moves are useful
is because of efficiency we especially
if you're playing in tournaments or
online
um and you're not playing like a
correspondence game
a big part of Chess is dealing with the
clock you only have so much time to make
your moves so it's important not only to
find the best moves when you can but
also to be efficient with how you spend
your time looking for moves I could look
at this position and try and look at it
for you know five hours and I could look
at every possible move I could look at
pushing these pawns I could look at
moving this Knight moving this Rook you
know you could look at every move and
say okay what if I do this what could
they do
you just don't have time there's not
enough time in the day or in the year
let alone
um
and it's not going to get you very far
in your chest so forcing moves are
incredibly efficient
um in this case
so yeah do you have an idea
[Music]
so we could
do a removable Defender
take away and
eliminate the night
so that we can Checkmate 100 you were
totally correct
um so let's look at this a little more
kind of uh one step at a time because
you're totally right
um but if you didn't see all that right
away the way you could solve this
position would be to say okay wait I see
that like you said the rook and the
queen are lined up against E2 and you
can imagine you're forcing moves maybe
Queen takes E2 or Rook takes let's say
you start with Rook takes and you're
like oh well if I then take with the
queen it's more powerful but you realize
the problem as you said this Knight on
G3 is defending so now we can look at
forcing moves again our next step is our
captures and checks
um we have this nice capture Bishop
takes G3 removing the defender and this
forces our opponent to respond not just
because we're taking the Knight but
because we're calling check so they have
to do something
if they take back if they recapture then
the night's gone and this will be our
checkmate
so they can't recapture which means they
have to move the good news here is you
know at the very least you're winning a
piece
because they can't take this back but
probably there is better
so uh Bishop takes G3
now we want to look at the next ideas if
they're not going to take back they have
to move the king
because they have to get out of this
check and they can't block on the Square
there's nothing to put so where can they
move their king after we play Bishop
takes G3
yes they got three moves
um I don't want to go too much into my
process yet we'll spend some time on
that later but the basic recommendation
I'm going to give is to say which one of
these three moves do you think is the
easiest for us to refute
essentially we either want to say this
this move is going to be the easiest for
us to beat or the easiest one to beat us
what do you think
okay
well you're close but then the king will
go back to C1
there is
a mate somewhere there is a mate
somewhere
um but I would actually say starting
with F1 is going to be easier
so let's imagine takes King to F1 I
think this is going to be easier to beat
because I'm going to do the same thing
as before I'm going to take on E2
um in this case you only have one move
you have to go back to G1 and can you
find Checkmate from that position
[Music]
yeah actually the bishop also works
either one so if this is what happens
check then either bishop or queen to F2
is Checkmate we win the game so we have
proven that that doesn't work uh you
can't go here so we've we can eliminate
that in our calculations now we want to
look at these two
for this example I'll put these moves on
the board to make it a little easier to
see but the good news is actually
regardless if we play Queen takes E2
next another forcing move because our
opponent only has one option
whether they go to D2 or to D1 they will
then have to go to C1 which means those
two lines are going to transpose and we
don't actually have to think of them as
separate lines anymore
for example here
this is the exact same position as if
they had played right here
there's actually no difference in the
positions it's just the move order so we
get to this position and again it's very
forcing the answer here as uh Moroccan
Nakamura that's a really great name and
the chat has pointed out
um yeah the next forcing move we have to
look at is just bringing the bishop back
to F4 a really nice check and what is
very limited in their options they can
block with the queen but that should be
a very easy win for us or they can block
with the Knight
and if they do this can anyone find the
kind of forcing move to get a checkmate
not in one move but in two
yes Queen to E1 check sacrificing the
queen normally wouldn't be a good idea
but because it's forcing we can very
quickly eliminate this idea and say okay
if they take well now we notice this
back rank pattern the king is totally
stuck behind all of these pieces and we
have won
um okay so hopefully that is a little
bit valuable in thinking about
efficiency right we don't have to waste
our time on every move calculating what
if I played Pawn to C5 or what if they
play Bishop to A3 you can really cut
down both on your own moves and your
opponents by looking at what are the
most forcing options in this case we
found ones that worked and forced our
opponent to get checkmated but even if
you don't you can still sometimes win
material or just quickly go through the
whole line and say okay none of these
forcing moves do any good for me so now
I can start to look at non-forcing moves
okay so that was the first reason
forcing moves are super useful is
because they are uh very good at helping
us be efficient in how we calculate
positions
the second way that I think they're very
helpful is in inducing creativity
helping us to be more creative in how we
play chess
so for this I actually want to show a
very common uh position
not the most common but it happens a lot
and it's a very useful pattern if you
haven't seen it before so we have E4 E5
Knight to F3 D6 again the Philadelphia
defense Bishop to C4
Bishop to G4 Knight to C3
Knight 2 C6 Pawn to H3 attacking the
bishop and the bishop drops back to H5
and what might surprise you is in this
position white has a slight advantage in
this one white is dominating
and I want you to take a little bit of
time to try and find the best
continuation for white
and we're going to kind of walk through
this together but if you have ideas feel
free to kind of raise your hand or say
something in the chat but I'm just going
to kind of point out some things I
noticed we want to start with our
forcing moves so again you can think
about checks and captures but mostly you
want to think about moves that limit
your opponent's responses and that they
are forced to respond to
so for example a very common type of
idea could be something like Bishop
takes F7 this is a check it's a capture
uh the only legal moves there's only I
guess four legal moves black would have
in this position
they could take with the King they could
move the king out of the way to one of
these two squares or they could take
with the bishop
you can spend some time looking at this
one and seeing if it works
um and it then we can identify the what
I like to do first is identify all of
our forcing moves so that looks very
forcing what are the other forcing moves
we have in this position
besides Bishop takes F7
if we have any that could be the only
one
yep okay
and we'll see if you can tell me so yeah
Knight takes E5 is a capture I believe
it's the only other really forcing move
in this position
um
but is it the legals me what do you
think
I'll let you keep thinking about that
um username zero four one six uh that's
amazing uh G4 is also a forcing that I
did not consider G4 we would attack the
bishop and force it to retreat if they
don't want to lose it or do something
this would be a big threat so that's
another good one to consider in the
position
so what do you think
there
is
able to go back oh and then only if
they capture
the queen yeah so okay so you were
totally correct um but let's actually
break this down so the idea is Knight
takes C5 looks like an insane move
because it's like wait a minute we're
one we're just attacking a knight that's
defended by a pawn
but then you look at it a little closer
and you realize wait a minute okay if
they actually took the Knight then our
Queen takes their Bishop so okay we
would just win a center Pawn if they
take back and that's true if they take
with the Knight or with the pawn we'll
explore that a little more in depth in a
moment the bigger problem it seems is
not only are we taking a pawn but
actually our Knight is pinned we're
going to lose our Queen
this is a pattern that's really famous
called legal's mate or legal's trap
where
we can play this but even if you don't
recognize the pattern just thinking
about these forcing moves that look very
unnatural can help you find the truth of
the position
if Bishop takes Queen
what is our forcing continuation
Bishop takes F7 defended by the Knight
it's a forcing move black only has one
legal move King to E7
yes Knight to D5 and we actually cover
every single square that this King could
go to this is Checkmate really really
beautiful queen sacrifice to get
checkmate here
there is one slight complication here I
want you to calculate here Knight takes
E5 Knight takes
Queen takes H5 and then Knight takes C4
wait aren't we losing two pieces we're
losing our Knight and our Bishop but
Black's only lost their Bishop what's
wrong with this for black
so Knight takes E5 Knight takes Queen
takes H5 and then our Knight their
Knight takes on C4 it seems like we've
lost two pieces
but a few people in the chat are correct
um
I don't know how to pronounce your name
I apologize but
the problem with this is we have another
forcing move it will be a little easier
to see once I put it on the board
what is our forcing move to win back the
material and maintain our advantage here
correct Queen to B5 forking the king and
the Knight
and we are going to pick it back up
whatever black plays
we can take the Knight and what happens
in the end well we won the center E5
Pawn we only won a pawn it seems like
that's a lot of work to get upon but it
is a center pawn and uh black is totally
undeveloped we have decent development
Our Queen maybe is a little misplaced
but black doesn't have any good way to
attack her and we're up a pawn
okay so uh first thing with forcing
moves they help us be efficient in our
calculations you don't have to spend as
much time because you know what to look
for second thing with forcing moves is
they can help us look Beyond what's a
normal looking move right it is very
unnatural to play a move that not only
sacrifices Our Queen but also just
attacks something defended by a pawn
with a piece but this is the best move
here uh it's the only winning move
so being able to use forcing moves to
our advantage to calculate and be
creative is super super helpful the
third thing I like about forcing moves
is they can reveal truths about
positions
so I want to for this one look at a game
that I played we're not going to go all
the way through but just the opening of
it so I was playing in a tournament here
at the St Louis chess club and I had the
white pieces my opponent played C5 the
Sicilian Defense I played Pawn to C3 the
allopin variation of the C3 Sicilian
looking to play Pawn to D4
Knight to C6 Pawn to D4 takes takes and
I knew from my opening study that the
only good move for my opponent in this
position is to play Pawn to D5 and the
reason for that is they need to stop me
from playing my own Pawn to D5
my opponent did not they played Pawn to
D6 which tells me okay I'm gonna play
this move
and here I wasn't really sure what to do
um in the game I decided I'm just going
to develop with some Tempo get an attack
on the night so I played Knight to F3
my opponent played the move Bishop to G4
and I something's put a little fishy
about this I said okay you're putting a
lot of pressure on me if I just have to
play like Bishop E2 and unpin that seems
like I've missed something it seems like
I have an opportunity here
so in this position see if you can take
a second and look through some forcing
moves and find the best continuation for
whites
this one is a little harder
and if you're having trouble my advice
is to again start with the forcing moves
right what are our forcing moves in this
position
um
check okay what else
okay and I take C5 just like last game
uh capture
H3 would be a forcing move attacking the
bishop
there's still at least one more
Yeah clean the A4 check and there might
be more forcing moves but those are the
ones I was really considering in my game
now I actually very quickly eliminated
H3
um I didn't like H3 because I well
the problem is it's actually forcing my
they have to move this bishop but it's
actually I think they kind of want to
because if they take now I can't take
back with the queen I'll lose it to the
Knight which means I have to double my
pawns not the end of the world but maybe
not like the most ideal thing either
there's some counter play here certainly
maybe now I have this open file for my
Rook against their King but
um I decided I didn't really want to
give them at least some Advantage
potentially
so that left me looking at Bishop B5 and
queen A5 and I looked at these for a
while
but there's a problem with both of these
moves what is wrong with or why is
Bishop B5 it looks so good this king is
very trapped
um
it can't move at all but how can black
survive this
um
you can move the night item to see free
or D7 well you don't want to move the
Knight to C6 because then I'm going to
take it with my Pawn but you're but you
can move the Knight to D7 and you can
also move the bishop to D7
so there's two pieces you can drop back
and maybe I have a slight Advantage
because I forced one of these pieces to
retreat I'm going to have a nice pin
that seems reasonable Queen A5 probably
slightly worse because now after Bishop
D7 you've at least gained some
initiative
against my queen
so I was thinking okay the problem these
two forcing moves look so good and so
natural but the problem is you have a
knight and a bishop to block this Square
and then that's how I figured it out
that looking at those forcing moves
taught me very simply
if I can get rid of these two pieces
then I'm fine if I can get rid of these
two pieces I'm actually winning a queen
right check and I the queen has to block
and I have a way to get rid of them if I
take this Knight with Knight takes E5
I've gotten rid of one of them
and you have to do something if you take
back I take your Bishop so I'm still
winning there
um if you just move the bishop away then
I've won a knight you know so
you have to take the queen it's the only
thing you can try but I already know I
can give this up because I can win a new
one check
clean blocks
check
and in this position I played another
forcing move Knight takes F7 check for
king of the king and the Rook
King takes bishop and what's the best
move for white here
take the work is good
better is taking the bishop because this
work is trapped
you can't move either way so we're going
to get this no matter what black plays
but we don't want to let this bishop get
away so first we take the bishop and now
whatever move I think in the game Knight
to F6 was played now we can just take
the Rook
and I'm up nine points of material I am
ashamed to say I lost this game but
hopefully it has at least been
instructive on using forcing moves
um okay so our three reasons for forcing
moves one efficiency two creativity
third even if they don't work themselves
they can still teach you about the
position and help you find a better move
okay with that under our belt let's
excuse me move along
um Okay so
and I'm actually going to
go here
okay
so I want to quickly talk about my
process for how do you apply forcing
moves in your games I've just kind of
put this nice little uh double Rook
Checkmate in the background
um yeah so Andrew quick Side Story
um I lost because I had Checkmate in one
move and I touched the wrong rook and so
I touch move I had to move it and I just
ended up losing a rook for free in the
very end and then I went on to lose a
very close King and pawn end game but uh
okay so forcing moves
and actually maybe it'll be a little
helpful if we go back to that previous
example one more time to kind of let me
help identify my process so I need to
quickly jump down here okay
when used properly forcing moves let us
calculate efficiently open us to
thinking outside the box and reveal
these positional truths but there is a
problem with forcing moves before I get
into the process of how we use them I
have to say this really big problem the
problem is if we spend every turn
looking at forcing moves we will be
playing a single game of chess for the
rest of our lives
in the opening position the good news is
in this position there's actually not
really any forcing moves because we
can't get too close to our opponent or
Force anything but you know very quickly
you'll start to find
that you know forcing moves already in
this position we're making a threat
maybe it's not the most serious threat
because they can defend but you know
forcing moves happen so often and in so
many positions it's really important to
ask yourself when do I actually need to
stop and look for all the forcing moves
and when do I not have to do that
uh and I would say there's a few
different kind of examples in this game
when my opponent played Pawn to D6 I
knew from opening preparation that this
was not a good move I knew that they had
to stop me from playing D5 so already in
this position well in this case I knew
why they couldn't do that but even if
here I don't know why they can't do that
I should say that's an unusual move if
you were someone who plays chess games
and don't like it when your opponent
plays really weird openings
there's a good remedy and it's to think
there's a reason the moves they're
playing are is unusual like there's a
reason I don't see this move a lot and
it's probably because it's bad which
means if you take a little bit of time
and can try and reason out why it's bad
you might be able to find the right
answer in this case I knew what the
answer was but it also happens to be our
forcing move right Pawn to D5 is forcing
this Knight to flee it's taking space in
the center
and in this position the move Knight to
F3 isn't terrible but it's not the best
actually the best move here is Pawn to
F4 again forcing this Knight to move
again taking space in the center
eventually I am going to play Knight F3
but I just I don't have this Pawn behind
it I'm threatening to really just break
through with fawn to E5
um
and White's just kind of dominating I
think if you turn on the computer in
this position it's like plus two plus
three
um
but even with missing this move
I still already know that there's
something weird going on because my
opponent is playing moves that I know
aren't supposed to be good and I have to
find out why
so that has alerted what I call my
tactical radar
this sense that okay this is the type of
position I need to be looking for
tactics
it's not the only thing the other things
in this particular position are the
presence of an exposed King
we we noticed very quickly that Bishop
to B5 and queen to A4 both look like
very strong moves
so noticing that there's a king that is
exposed to be attacked
um in a previous lesson I did called
loose pieces drop off uh you can find
that lecture on YouTube I also talked
about any time there are unprotected
pieces in this particular case these
aren't so much unprotected but if I get
rid of the Knight the bishop does become
unprotected and this discovery works so
looking for little tactical patterns
um like like unprotected pieces or an
exposed king or
um even like pieces lined up you know so
in this case we have a pin
a pin is also a potential discovery
so looking for pieces that are lined up
or batteries or you know back rank
patterns that's a very common one if you
see there's potentially a king that
could be back ranked that can lead to
some really good tactical radar so and
probably the best way to increase this
for yourself is to work on puzzles
um you can do either short-term puzzles
or like kind of quick try and solve them
fast like puzzle Rush type stuff or
spending more time with puzzles both of
them are going to give you a benefit the
benefit to those quicker puzzles is
they're going to improve your pattern
recognition you've got to see what's
going on on the board really quick
longer puzzles are going to help you
visualize what's going on better you're
going to spend more time analyzing all
the different variations
but all of that is to help you build
what I call your Tactical radar
so here's the process in very kind of a
nutshell version that I use in my own
Games first thing I reach some position
where my tactical radar is flickering
I'm like okay for some reason either
they've done some weird opening or I see
there's an exposed King and some
unprotected pieces or maybe I have a
battery that I can use but I'm noticing
there's something in the position that
tells me I should slow down and look for
some tactics
the second thing I want to do is
identify my candidate moves what are all
the forcing moves I have in this
position
after that I want to identify which of
these is the most forcing
look at all of my opponents possible
responses
and then I kind of want to calculate
what is the easiest line to prove or
refute I either want to show
definitively that whatever specific
variation I'm looking at is going to be
advantageous for me or disadvantageous
for me because if I can prove one or the
other very quickly I can just move on to
the next move down the line I either
know oh this is what I want to do and
play it or this is not what I want to do
I got to move to the next one
um eventually once you've evaluated all
those options
and you've repeated until you either
find something that's really
advantageous or not
you either just play it or if you don't
find one
you look at your non-forcing moves you
say okay maybe no forcing moves work in
this position and you can start looking
at the natural but not forcing moves
developing controlling the center King
safety
building potential Forks or you know all
the good stuff that we look at in our
positional play
so let's go through this process
in this position
it is white to move this is a complex
idea there's actually a few different
ideas here the first one maybe not so
much but the second one is much more so
but I want you to take a little bit and
using what we've looked at with forcing
moves the downside with a puzzle is the
puzzle just being a puzzle tells you the
Tactical radar is there right it tells
you there is something to find in this
position
but even if we don't know that right
even if I'm just showing you this there
are some things you might start to
notice about potential tactical ideas
so even if you don't see the full
solution if anyone has reasons why their
tactical radar might be flickering in
this position feel free to put them out
there
are you raising your hand
Rook night and rope
[Music]
okay really good I'm going to come back
to in a second but I want to even stop
you there because that's really helpful
one you noticed uh our rook and Knight
are lined up with Black's Rook meaning
we have Discovery potential
um already that's a good tactical vision
and then you notice wait one of our
forcing moves is to call a check we can
call check which means after they
resolve this
um our work is going to be able to take
their Rook
okay so Knight to G6 what are all of our
opponents possible moves
yes so and that's it right they're in
check by the night
um they can either take it or move their
King and they only have one square to
move it which of those do you think is
the easiest to prove either prove it
works for you or it doesn't
like do which one of these do you think
is easier to show whether it's going to
give you an advantage or not
mm-hmm
I I agree because
yeah so if we play Knight G6 and they
don't take it this is checkmate
so already in your head you can say okay
I don't have to think about this line
anymore I've proven it doesn't work for
black let's move on to the next one what
about H takes
uh-huh
so after
1986
H takes G6 Rook takes
f8 and you're you
get a good exchange yeah so we're going
to be up in exchange in this position
we're actually dead even on material
it's a little imbalanced we have a rook
and upon versus the bishop pair but we
are going to give up a night and get a
rook
good enough for me I'm happy
but now
my tactical radar is still going off
we have an advantage sure but there's
still something that seemed a little
fishy this one is the harder one but now
see if you can find
how white can prove beyond a shadow of a
doubt even though we're up a little
material we just want to prove this one
way or another so what are our forcing
moves in this position
okay so we have two checks both
sacrifices Queen H6 Rook h8 what other
forcing moves do we have let's just
identify as many as we can
there's probably not a lot more but
there are at least a few
yeah it's a capture
um I don't know that this one is as much
a forcing move because even though we're
capturing they don't have a way to
recapture so there's not something we're
specifically forcing them to do but it
is still good to look at right this is
maybe one of those examples where I
would say a capture is not exactly a
forcing move because it's not forcing
our opponent to do any one thing
but still a good potential move but
let's start with the forcing moves okay
between Queen H6 and Rook h8 which one
do you think is the easiest one to prove
again either prove that it works or
prove that it doesn't
okay so you think Queen H6 is easy to
prove
what do you think the line is or well
well
uh yeah so the way yeah I'm trying to
solve this is what are all Black's
possible responses
yeah they're gonna block a bunch but uh
yes precisely so uh actually yeah Queen
H6 is the easier one in this case
um Rook to h8
some could argue is easier because
there's just no solution but uh but if
you can already see Queen H6 is the best
move because black has two responses
take with the pawn or take with the King
between those two we narrowed it down
and said taking with the king is easier
to refute because if they take with the
King then actually simply playing Rook
to h8 will be Checkmate it's kind of a
reverse back rank or like a sideways
back rank
um
because our Pawn covers this square and
our Rook hits all three of these
so we can say Okay Queen H6 but what if
they take with a pawn well now we have
the idea we saw earlier that you pointed
out is we can take this but it's
actually much better to wait because if
this Pawn is out of the way
then this is going to be a check again a
forcing move
and Black's Pawn will be on H6 our Rook
is still covering this rank so this is
just the game is over Queen to H6 takes
check and black can delay the inevitable
they can throw a bunch of pieces in the
way but eventually this will be a check
mate and we found it this kind of crazy
Queen H6 sacrifice move because we were
willing to say either your Tactical
radar was alerted or because you know it
was a puzzle you knew there was
something here but either way we looked
at some forcing moves so looking at air
forcing moves can help you really
efficiently find the right solution to
puzzles and in your games and can also
show you okay I've looked at a bunch of
options and none of these are working
let's move on to the non-forcing
candidate moves as well
okay
um
let's take a look at this position here
because I think it's very important to
apply the idea of forcing moves both to
your own moves and also to your
opponents so in this case let's imagine
that you've spent a lot of time because
I don't have as much time left to help
do this on your own let's imagine you
playing this in a game and you've spent
enough time to rule out the obvious
forcing moves let's say you say H6
Knight G or Knight F6 check Bishop takes
you you look at all these and you say
they're no good
so now you have to find your own move
but you're also starting to realize that
black has some forcing moves of Their
Own
this move Rook to A1 check is a
potential forcing move that you need to
consider
um perhaps Knight takes F3 attacking a
rook is a move you need to consider
so see if you can identify the best
sequence for your opponent let's say it
was
um maybe black starting to move what
would they play here and then how can we
solve that for us so yeah Brandon go
ahead
night takes on either they give up the
records yes so our fourth thing was
really valuable because when we see
these two moves together Knight takes F3
there we either save our Rook or we save
our King because this move not is
actually a fork it's forking The Rook on
G1 it's also forking the D2 Square which
is where our King needs to escape
so let me just play some silly move
we have to now uh save our King
something like King to B1 giving up our
Rook
because if we don't
this is checkmates
okay so that is the threat
how can we stop it
can we stop it
King to B1 is playable
the only reason King to be one isn't
like the best it does stop Rook to A1
and we don't have to worry about those
checkmates but they are going to pick up
this Pawn on F2 or sorry on F3 so if we
can avoid giving up the pawn that's
probably slightly better okay
broadcast F1 which one or does or does
it matter
okay why
depends upon which is exactly why I
eliminated
and then the night
after we cannot happen upon in the first
place
and
but
and then
which also means that approach to a one
is not made but why didn't I do Rook to
G3 well
there is Knight to E2 which is a fourth
and yeah okay so yeah I agree Rook G3
defending the pawn is not so good as you
said we found this forcing check
um it actually surprisingly does matter
which of these two Rooks you use
um it's a again maybe a little more
advanced than the beginner breakdown is
ready for but actually Rook Dita F1 is a
mistake perhaps even a blunder because
still forcing moves are quite valuable
and actually the best move here for
black is the same idea we looked at
before
Knight takes F3 forking our rook and our
uh Escape Square the difference here is
that when we take back
they pick up the Rook like this
this does not work if we play Rook from
F to uh or sorry work from G to F1
because now uh well now if you take
my king is still defending this Rook so
this actually doesn't help you and
there's not really any it doesn't matter
if you switch the move order like taking
here doesn't really make a difference
all of my things are still defended
um okay so that's basically all the time
we have but I want to thank you for
coming hopefully this has been helpful
in learning about forcing moves and
applying them to your games uh and I
hope to I hope you stick around uh
actually we have our grandmaster's
choice class with Grandmaster Igor
novakov so please stick around for that
should be really exciting but otherwise
I hope you take care and see ya see you
later
[Music]